- [Instructor] Every few years
you might hear about El Nino
in the news.
And this also might come
with powerful images
of flooding and rainfall,
but it is not just a storm.
It's actually a climate
pattern that takes place
in the Pacific Ocean.
And we'll get a little bit more
into what that actually means.
Now, fun fact about how El Nino is named
is that a long time ago,
South American fishermen
noticed one December
that the Pacific Ocean was actually warmer
than it normally is.
And this brought about
an abundance of fish.
So because they were grateful,
they named this event
El Nino to correlate
with the commemoration
of Christ in this part of the
world during Christmas time.
So that's a little trivia you
can keep in your back pocket,
but back to what we hear
about El Nino in the news,
you might also notice
that it isn't talked about
every single year and that's
because El Nino comes around
every two to seven years on average.
And scientists are still not sure exactly
what triggers El Nino, but
they know what signs to look
for once it is approaching
or once we're in that event.
So even though it's true
that El Nino can bring about
heavy rainfall and flooding,
it can also cause severe drought.
So it's really important to
note that different regions
around the world experience
different effects of El Nino.
And we'll see a few examples of those.
So sometimes an El Nino year is actually,
a little bit helpful and might bring
about some much needed rain,
but other times bigger and
more severe El Nino events
can bring devastating weather
events all across the globe.
So we can look at the different effects
by looking at the biggest
El Nino on record,
during the 1997 to 1998 season.
And we can see how different
regions were affected.
So for example, in California,
we saw very destructive mudslides.
In Ecuador, there was heavy rainfall.
And in Indonesia there was actually
extreme drought and fire.
And overall, this El Nino
event was really large
and very destructive, there are estimates
of about $36 billion in
damage to infrastructure.
So you might be asking yourself,
how can the same climate
pattern caused such drastically
different effects around the globe?
So to understand this better,
we have to look at what a quote unquote
normal year looks like.
So this is a map of the Pacific Ocean.
And normally there are winds
that are pushing warm water
towards the West.
So towards Asia and the Pacific islands
and warm water accumulates on this side,
on the other side on the East side,
near Central and South America,
we have an accumulation of cool water.
And this is also due to a
process called upwelling,
where cold water from the bottom
of the ocean is pushed up.
And during these conditions in general,
you would see less rain on this side.
Or you'll see more rain on this side.
Okay, so now let's look
at what changes during
an El Nino year.
So during an El Nino year,
you still have trade
winds pushing water West,
but they're much weaker
and that's the key here,
that your trade winds are weakened,
which means less water is pushed
towards Asia and the Pacific islands.
So compared to a normal year,
you actually have cooler water
that starts to accumulate
on this side of the Pacific Ocean.
Meanwhile, on the other side,
since less water is being
pushed away from Central
and South America, you get
more warm water accumulating.
So now you can think back to
those South American fishermen
and why they were experiencing warm water
along their coasts during an El Nino year.
So this map does a really great job
of showing the temperature gradient,
and how this warm water
is staying along the coast
of Central and South America
during an El Nino year.
Meanwhile, you have cold water
accumulating towards Asia.
And this causes a lot of changes
that affect weather patterns.
So in the US the Pacific jet stream
moves South of its neutral position.
And because of that, we start to see
that the Northern US and
Canada are actually warmer
and drier than they usually are.
The US Gulf Coast and Southwest regions
of the US are wetter,
and are there more
increased risk for flooding.
And South Asia and the Pacific
islands experience warmer
and drier conditions that lead to drought
on the other side of the Pacific Ocean.
So now you start to see
how one event El Nino,
this one climate pattern
can cause both flooding
on one side of the Pacific Ocean,
while also causing
drought on the other side.
And finally, we'll end with La Nina,
because you might hear this come up too
when talking about El Nino.
So La Nina is essentially the opposite.
So if you've got El Nino down,
you can start to understand what happens
during La Nina event.
So in this situation,
our trade winds are getting
stronger than our normal years.
So they're pushing water West,
but they're doing so even more
than we normally would expect.
So this warm water that accumulates
towards Asia actually
accumulates more West
than it would during our normal years.
And on the other side, we
have even more upwelling
causing this cold water to accumulate.
So the next time you hear El
Nino or LA Nina in the news,
you'll know that they're not just talking
about a really big storm,
but they're actually talking
about climate patterns
that can affect weather
all across the globe.